the village of the metrica is recovering
from a month-long siege by russian
forces
it was a front line in the battle for
the capital kiev
and the wounds are still wrong
thank god we survived we lived here by
the forest where all the houses were
bombed where everything was burned
that's where we lived we were bombed 24
hours without stopping we never thought
that we can survive here in this village
we survived armageddon stalingrad this
is stalingrad
as the russian forces tried to withdraw
they were ambushed by waiting ukrainian
artillery
heavy fighting continued for almost 24
hours here on this road just outside
dimitrijka
severely shelled a column of russian
tanks and personnel carriers were wiped
out
many soldiers remained inside now barely
recognizable
those who survived the fight were
captured a video showing the killing of
one of the prisoners of war has since
emerged which has caused outrage
right here the ukrainian forces captured
two russian soldiers one of them was
still alive and gasping then a soldier
shot the man twice and after the man
kept moving the soldier shot him again
and the man stopped the killings
happened around march 13th while a
russian column was retreating from the
area the ukrainian defense ministry said
the destruction of a russian convoy here
was precise work however the video shows
a more complicated reality
russian colonel bogdan was a soldier for
42 years before he retired
when the war started he took up arms
again
he questions the video's authenticity
videos
this video was edited when we get
prisoners we detain and trade them for
ukrainians
we are not barbarians we don't shoot
prisoners
while ukrainian officials allege russian
forces are committing war crimes against
civilians in the region now they face
similar accusations
they are promising to investigate
for everyone who died in this war
russians and ukrainians one person bears
a responsibility vladimir putin
as bullying a civilian this and even if
possibly our armed forces made some
violations which led to the death of
people still putin is responsible it is
not us who started the war but him
as for the rest it requires a
personalized approach case by case
according to the geneva conventions
according to the geneva conventions
this war shouldn't have happened
as the war grinds on and continues to
claim lives the fear here is off more
atrocities to come
al jazeera demetrius